what's happening here but my this last  one taken by itself it's scandalous it's  graphic oh my god yeah that's literally  my hand  those are my fingers yeah how would you  know that because that's a fingernail  this looks like it could be like you  guys are desperate  well yeah yeah right that could be a but  that could be a boot like could be a  scrotum no no I woke up in the morning  and I was taking pictures about cute I  like what happened in this one my food  arrived oh that was a real moment of my  foots yeah yeah oh yeah you have no idea  how many pictures of my own face I have  an iPhone oh yeah this is me and my mom  what holiday it was is who knows this  could be a Wednesday I don't know she  might be a are you getting married I  mean who's to say this is in my book and  this is I think my mom's wedding day to  my stepdad obviously because I'm born  thanks for watching ET on youtube if you  want more make sure to subscribe